it is great to welcome back to the
program today author and entrepreneur
Andrew yang who is as much of our
audience has known for a while because
we've been talking about his campaign
for some time now running as a Democrat
for president in 2020 Andrew great to
have you back and it seems like
everybody's talking about you now you're
you're talking to Fox Business and Fox
News and you're all over the place which
is a great thing well thank you David as
you say you and your audience knew about
me before anyone else but yeah I'm being
discovered more and more I'm gonna be on
MSNBC and CNN a little bit later this
week and I'm polling at 3% in Las Vegas
so we're off to the races well I'm gonna
be in Las Vegas soon so I'm gonna find
that three percent and talk to them
personally okay so there's a bunch of
stuff I mean now so last time when we
had you on fewer people knew about you
so when I said let me know what you want
me to talk to Andrew about there were
questions but there were fewer questions
now that your platform is much more
well-known the questions have just been
pouring in and there's a few things that
keep coming up that I feel like you and
I can just talk about and I think it
will be satisfactory to those who want
to inquire about this stuff so the first
thing is there's a sort of a contingent
which is alleging that you are sort of a
pro-business libertarian masquerading as
some kind of leftist or progressive or
that there's some hidden agenda that's
more represented by your business
background than by the politics you're
espousing now what do you say that the
people who are making those assertions
well no I'd love it if they dug into my
background because I think there's a
misconception that I'm some sort of like
whiz-bang tech entrepreneur which may
have some negative connotations among
some people that are are you know like
concerned about my motivations but if
they dig into what venture for America
is it's a 501c3 nonprofit that I started
in 2011 that helped train hundreds of
young entrepreneurs to create thousands
of jobs and places like Detroit
Cleveland same
Louis Birmingham Baltimore and other
cities around the country and it was
very deeply swimming work you know it
was young people it was small businesses
and it's still going strong to this day
and so I think there there's some just
there's some confusion and
misconceptions about Who I am and the
nature of my work this last number of
years that might lend to someone to to
the mistaken belief frankly that that
you know that there's reason to be
skeptical about my platform I
motivations but the platform is there
for everyone to see
and it would improve people's lives I
think most people on the Left can can
very easily see that it's among the most
progressive platforms in the race and I
put that platform front and center
because that's what I believe like
there's no there's no agenda here I'm
one of the only candidates that's
actually put out now 80 policy proposals
for the world to see and when you look
at the rest of the Democratic field if
someone said how do you position
yourself within that field on the basis
of your policies do you feel as though
you are on the left spectrum of the
current Democratic contenders do you
feel that you are closer to the middle
do you think that it's not an
appropriate spread-spectrum that you're
sort of outside of that box yeah sorry
my family just returned but I figure
that might be welcoming for some people
so you know again my policies are out
there for everyone to see
and you know certainly I've been
characterized as being the among the
most progressive candidates in this race
and I would agree with that
characterization but you know I'd leave
it for others to make their own
determination I will say that putting
$1,000 a month into every American
adults hands immediately would be the
most transformative move in a
progressive direction that we've
undertaken in generations okay so I want
to dick now that we're ready to dig into
more detail on UB I will get into that
one last thing on this sort of secret
alt-right guy stuff that's circulating
just so we can sort of put it to bed but
the white nationalist Richard Spencer
tweeted positively about you talking
about what he calls white death and
deindustrialization and automation and
so on and so forth this is a guy I've
interviewed he's a key player
in the white nationalist out right right
now that's not someone whose support
you're interested in I presume yeah I've
already disavowed the support of anyone
who has any kind of agenda of
hatefulness or racism and I you know I
said look I don't want their support and
if you look at me and my background I'm
the son of immigrants you know I've been
been working like you know it like in a
progressive direction for years and
years and so I have limited control over
some of the people that decide that my
platform is something they're interested
in but I've already disavowed the
support of anyone who has beliefs that
are antithetical to mine in that way
okay let's now get into ubi you and I
initially connected over Universal
Universal basic income something I've
been covering for years at this point
I'm a supporter of ubi the devil is in
the details as is often the case so I
think this is a good opportunity to talk
about some of the questions that there
are around how you would structure it
you call it the freedom dividend you're
talking about a thousand dollars a month
for all Americans not means-tested is
that a good general overview of how you
see the proposal yeah that's exactly
right okay so the questions that have
come up are around the idea of replacing
existing welfare benefits with ubi so
for example someone who might be getting
$300 worth of food stamps per month
already would if I understand correctly
only get 700 of the thousand maximum
dollars that would be available under
the freedom dividend is that an accurate
understanding as well that's generally
correct the freedom dividend is meant to
be opt in but if you opt in and you're
saying look I prefer this to the 300
dollars that I'm getting so in that
particular case that would be right so
my concern with that is the following
I've always thought that one of the
primary goals of ubi
should be to raise the standard of
living for as many people as possible in
a way that makes a difference in their
lives which i think is an important part
of
and so what concerns me about the way I
think you've outlined the plan and of
course you'll have an opportunity to
tell me if I'm if I'm misunderstanding
it is that if someone is extraordinarily
wealthy without the means-testing they
get an additional thousand dollars a
month if someone is already receiving
$1000 a month of welfare benefits on the
basis that their income qualifies them
those would be simply replaced dollar
for dollar with your thousand dollar
freedom dividends so in practice you
could have something which I agree
should not be means-tested I'm
completely with you there but that ends
up giving rich people who don't need an
extra thousand dollars a month a
thousand dollars and leaving people
already on welfare with a thousand from
ubi
instead of a thousand from other
programs yeah and and so there are a few
elements to this David the first is that
I want to fund this with value-added tax
that would end up harvesting a lot of
money from that person at the very top
of the pyramid because right now and if
you look at the person at the very tippy
top someone like Jeff Bezos he's worth
160 billion dollars in Amazon paid zero
in federal taxes last year okay so so my
plan would generate literally billions
of dollars from Amazon by giving the
American people a slice of every Amazon
transaction and every Google search and
every Facebook ad and every robot truck
mile and then this would be the the net
was we would end up harvesting literally
billions maybe tens of billions of
dollars from Jeff Bezos so if we then
send him a thousand dollars a month to
remind him that he's an American then
you know especially as you say there are
many benefits to not means-testing it so
the goal is to destigmatize this program
and say look this is a new right of
citizenship it's just like in Alaska
everyone gets it like we're not gonna
monitor you we're not going to keep
track of changes and circumstances we're
not going to make this a rich to poor
transfer but the net effect is that it
does end up getting money from the
people that are in position to benefit
the most from our society so that's the
first big thing is that the fun
mechanism ends up making it so that the
the wealthy who are great at frankly
avoiding income taxes end up paying
their fair share well I want to talk
about the VAT tax specifically so I'm
glad you mentioned it and we'll get to
that I still can't get away from the
reality though that if you currently
have a thousand dollars a month in
welfare benefits that you're receiving
the freedom dividend goes into play and
they still get just that same thousand
dollars I'm unsure how those individuals
are benefiting if they're just swapping
a thousand dollars from a couple of
programs for a thousand dollars from the
freedom dividend what about those
individuals are they better off yes so
there are at least three ways in which
they're better off okay so the first is
that a lot of the existing programs have
have monitoring and requirements you
have a case manager and so if you've
said look you can have a thousand
dollars no questions asked that's
actually an improvement for the person
in that situation it's even higher so to
speak they don't have to continually
verify that they continue to qualify for
the program yes and another advantage to
that too is that right now that there
are some games playing going on where
you know it's like you can't report
anything past a certain level or else
your benefits are reduced so one your
reporting goes down to the incentives
change three there's no stigma because
now everyone's getting it and like you
know that there's no negative
association and the fourth thing is that
in many cases these people have children
that if they have children and as soon
as the child turns 18 that child starts
getting $1,000 a month that's a game
changer and I'm a parent as you can tell
and so if you're a parent and you know
that your children will start receiving
$1,000 a month at age 18 that's an
enormous burden that's lifted if you
were a parent which in many cases
there's a young person in the family
that when they become 18 this would be
an enormous change in circumstances so
let's talk about the funding mechanism a
little bit and you and I have not talked
about this before you talked about the
the VAT tax of value-added tax and the
idea would be really rich people like
Jeff Bezos as you mentioned are going
you know the he can reduce his wages
significantly and avoid paying income
tax on wages capital gains taxes are low
so the VAT tax is a way to actually get
more money in a more difficult to avoid
way from somebody like Jeff Bezos my
concern is that that taxes are notorious
for on a percentage basis being
overwhelmingly borne by poor people
rather than rich people and I'll explain
what what I mean by that just so it's
clear to the audience when you are a
very wealthy person and a VAT tax is
placed on your consumption it's true
that in terms of the number of dollars
you are likely going to pay
significantly more dollars in terms of a
VAT tax than a poor person but because
the poor person has a much higher what's
called marginal propensity to consume
they are more likely to need every last
dollar they have to fund their more
meager lifestyle on a percentage basis
the poor person pays more of their
income to the VAT tax than the very rich
person that seems to run counter to the
goals of your proposal am I missing
something about how that taxes work in
practice so um you are largely correct
in a way that we can amend this is that
VAT tax is in other parts so first we're
the only advanced economy in the world
right now that does not have a VAT
value-added tax because as you say
they're much much more efficient at
getting the revenue from the Jeff Bezos
of the world who are expert at not
paying a whole lot of income tax but in
other countries as well
they have value-added taxes that are
effectively higher on luxury goods that
get consumed by people of greater means
and lower or even total exemptions on
consumer staples that are consumed by
the poor so you're a hundred percent
correct that in a vacuum the value-added
tax
ends up being a bigger burden on someone
with less money because you know it's
like that that incremental cost is a
bigger deal if you are living on a fixed
income than if you are swimming in money
but there are ways to make the
value-added tax less burdensome
people with the least and that that
would be the plan in other countries
again have already done this how do you
do that do you exempt certain spending
from the VAT tax yeah that's exactly
right
like you just exempt various consumer
staples that you know that working-class
Americans end up spending more of their
income on and the the trade-off that is
you get less money which is fine because
to me they go with a VAT is to go where
the money is not where the money isn't
but yeah you could you could exempt
various consumer staples and then you
get less revenue but that would be the
plan so in essence it becomes more of a
luxury VAT tax so to speak yeah that's
right we're speaking with Andrew yang he
is running for president in 2020 in the
Democratic primary we will continue our
conversation with him on tomorrow's
program talking about free college or as
I prefer to call it college page through
taxation it's not actually free we'll
pick up the conversation with him then
we're continuing our conversation today
with twenty twenty Democratic
presidential candidate Andrew yang he is
an author he is an entrepreneur he's
joined us on the program a couple of
times before Andrew I want to continue
our conversation talking about what some
call free college what I call college
paid through tax revenues talk to us
about your position on that idea which
was popularized I guess most recently in
2016 by Bernie Sanders are you for it or
are you against that well I'm a hundred
percent for the spirit of it which is
that it's immoral the way we've crushed
younger people in particular by this
incredibly expensive education system
college has gotten two-and-a-half times
more expensive than when I went and it
hasn't gotten two and a half times
better and there are many families in
the US you know I mean I've got two
young kids and you look up and you'll be
like how much is college supposed to
cost the whole thing has gotten out of
control so so I'm all for the spirit of
it the the there are some issues though
with presenting it as the big move
because even after all these years of
prescribing college to young people only
about 33% of Amer
goons are going to graduate from college
and the six-year completion rate from
college if you start is only fifty nine
percent so forty one percent of people
are dropping out now some of that is
related to cost but some of that is
related to the fact that college is not
for everyone and so if you treat this as
your main economic fix then you're
really directing resources towards the
top third of the population and when you
graduate from college today you're you
have a forty four percent chance of
being underemployed in other words
you're doing a job that is not right now
requiring a college degree and that does
not change based upon the cost of your
education so so while we a hundred
percent need to rein in the cost of
college and bring it down to some sort
of normal affordability levels and we a
hundred percent have to take a we should
do large-scale forgiveness of this 1.5
trillion dollars in school loans that
have been accrued that is this crushing
weight on young people in particular we
need to do those things but we also need
to be realistic about the fact that
college is not for everyone and college
is not a cure-all and that presenting it
as such is actually perpetuating some
misconceptions in many Americans lives
and if you're thirty like what does free
public College do for you anyway you
know it's like if you well reduce a lot
if in ten years your kids will be in
college yeah but then again there is you
know like college is not for everyone
and if you're in like the 67% of the
population that's not going to end up
with a college degree like yeah you know
it may not benefit you directly and it's
speculative that you're gonna have a
child that you know that particular
point so it's much better just to put a
thousand bucks a month into everyone's
hands and say look if you're going to go
to college this will partially pay for
it if you go to vocational school this
will partially pay for it maybe entirely
pay for it if the program is inexpensive
enough if you want to start your own
business if you want to to do something
independent just putting a thousand
dollars a month into people's hands
would actually help introduce some level
of accountability in the cost of
education as well and I have separate
proposals and plans to reduce the cost
of college I want to go to colleges
say look if you don't you have to get
your prices in line or you're not going
to get access to federal aid anymore
which every college is dependent on and
so you can start enforcing some cost
discipline try and get there
administrator to student ratios down
because that's actually caused the
explosion and the cost of college so
this is a multi-faceted problem and just
saying like hey if I can get public
college tuition down we'll solve the
problem to me that there are a few other
pieces to the puzzle so I'm for the
spirit of it but my approach would be
somewhat different I believe would
benefit more Americans okay so there's a
ton there to dig into and maybe we can
try to break it down into some component
parts I mean first of all I completely
agree with you college isn't for
everyone
I disagreed that free tuition for public
colleges and universities is actually
going to lead to people that shouldn't
be going to college going to college for
a couple different reasons number one
you still have to get in right and
psychologists still have standards it's
not Community College you know where I
went undergraduate at the University of
Massachusetts you don't just get in
because you sign up it's not a Community
College so if it was tuition free I
don't actually I think you still have to
demonstrate that people who shouldn't be
going to college will be going if
anything it would make it more
competitive because there would be more
applications for a limited number of
seats so I don't know I don't think that
that's a legitimate concern that that
too many people will be going because a
lot of people don't want to go either
way
and they still have to get in yeah you
know it's true that what I'm what you're
describing I'm describing doesn't
necessarily make that problem worse but
what it does do is it still perpetuates
this message that we're sending to high
school kids that if you don't go to
college you have no future and right now
there's a massive under supply of people
heading into the trades and vocational
jobs which are going to be much more
resilient and stand the test of time
it's much easier frankly to automate
away like a bookkeeping job or an
accounting job or an entry-level
journalist job that existed X years ago
than it is to automate a way a plumber
and electrician like a line repair
person and only 6% of American high
school students right now are in
technical or
occasional training whereas in Germany
that's 59 percent so we're massive the
under-investing in vocational and
technical and apprenticeships and
frankly over-indexing to to college
graduates that that may well be but this
kind of gets to the other sort of
concern I have with the way your more
generally laying it out which is that
while it's true that lots of jobs have
not and will not require a college
degree to the extent that our
immigration policy remains more or less
what it is now in other countries more
and more people do have college degrees
and they are increasingly competitive
within the United States for the jobs
that do require college degrees so while
I agree with you that lots of jobs don't
require a college degree I would
question the idea of not taking
advantage of something that will get
more people in the US who want those
jobs to have degrees because otherwise
we're just going to lose those jobs in
the United States to people from other
countries now if you're not an economic
nationalist you don't care about that
right if you want full movement of labor
between countries and you say it so it's
just as good you do care about that
that's the thing yeah yeah I mean you
know I like I'm not anti college in the
least
you know like I'm like pro college and I
you know I want to help people afford
like attend college in affordable ways I
think the fact that all these states
have cut back on their aid to their
public university systems like in all
likelihood I think Massachusetts above
average in this regard but there are
many other states that have cut back
there the public support and so the
tuitions gone up and up and up like I'm
I'm a hundred percent for greater
support for public education and getting
that ticket price down particularly for
people who attend college in in-state
and and then if you have a reasonable
tuition level and you're getting a
thousand dollars a month during an age
18 then you you you can get to very very
affordable college very quickly now on
the cost of college I wonder and I'm
thinking out loud this isn't a
rhetorical question I'm genuinely
wondering if we think about the
different ways that we might be able to
reduce the cost of college if public
colleges and universities were tuition
free
wouldn't that put some downward pressure
on the private colleges and universities
to say we're now in competition this we
actually now need to
justify why someone would pay to come
here rather than to pay nothing or only
for books and fees depending on what we
mean by tuition free to go to a state or
a state college or university isn't that
a great way to introduce some
competition rather than all forces that
drive prices up for college like it
being easier and easier to get student
loans wouldn't free college tuition for
state colleges and universities put
downward pressure on prices at the
expense of private schools
yeah and might mean uh you know you're
reminding me of what the world was like
when I was going to college where my
brother attended a public university
with in-state tuition in large part
because the economic incentives to do so
and at that time private college was
less egregiously overpriced so there
could be a relationship there and so
again let me say that I am very very
much for affordable public education
yeah I dislike the fact that to me it's
it's sending like to me like a slightly
mistaken message that it's going to
address our larger economic and job
issues when the data suggests that it's
a more like complicated picture yeah for
sure and especially I mean the the what
you pay for college is related to there
are decisions that you make in terms of
what you're willing to pay for college
on the basis of what you expect to earn
when you graduate and that's also a
piece of the picture that has to be
dealt with which is not directly dealt
with simply by getting more people into
college you know what's really
interesting David is that if you look at
like the heritage of our university
system it was not meant to get people
jobs it's like it was actually meant to
educate the population and a lot of
liberal arts education is built upon
this we're like it then what expectation
wasn't that like oh if you get this
degree you're gonna go MIT make make a
mint it was to try and educate a
population for citizenship and
leadership in various ways we've
introduced the economic rationale a bit
late in the day so if you know it like
yet in an ideal world people would and
this was also this dates me a little bit
but there was a point when people were
choosing college majors based upon their
interests
that's shocking who would ever do that
yeah I know
like like that there was you know and
and and unfortunately now we live in an
era of such economic stress and duress
that now everyone's like oh like we got
to make college pay we got to make
college pay if you made her in that then
you're an idiot like blah blah blah and
I'm optimistic that like taking the
economic boot off people's throats
through the freedom dividend of $1,000 a
month before during and after college
might help change our educational
culture and very positive ways yeah I
mean however you do it and we might
disagree about how to do it making it so
that the cost of college is less
burdensome either through the universal
basic income making college less
expensive but whatever the the the point
is people will be better able to make
the decisions that are actually
decisions they they want to make in
terms of what their lives look like
rather than decisions that are sort of
forced upon them by by the economic
circumstances and it's hard to disagree
that that that's a good thing
you know limit is duh yeah $80 and like
the almighty dollar has overrun our
educational system the almighty dollar
has overrun most aspects of American
life and if we start undoing that then
we have a real chance but the subtext
really is that you know like if we're
trying to make everyone financially
accountable frankly we're gonna lose I
mean there needs to be some
accountability particularly in these
colleges because their costs have gotten
out of control but but you know if we
see everyone as an economic actor then
we're all gonna lose because artificial
intelligence and software coming that
are going to be very very hard for more
and more Americans to keep pace with
like we're in a race that we're going to
collectively lose and we need to change
the race to things that we can actually
excel at and win and without that
evolution it's going to be tougher and
tougher for educational institutions
okay in the last couple minutes we have
here just to touch base and get our
audience up to speed on what's going on
with the campaign are you in the debates
so to speak has have you reached all of
the requirements to participate in the
Democratic debates yeah we we
word now at something like 90 almost a
hundred thousand individual donors and
the threshold to qualify for the debates
with 65 thousand and we're already in
touch with the DNC so we have qualified
for both the June and July debates for
the DNC and we're super excited about it
and what is your strategy going to be in
a field that is relatively crowded
certainly more crowded than it was on
the Democratic side in 2016
what will your approach be and most
importantly will you be targeting anyone
with particular nicknames on stage yeah
I've got a nickname for everyone no I'm
kidding
you know that the plan is just to
introduce myself the American people
like most Americans are not paying much
attention to the race just yet unlike
the people who are like watching
listening to you David I think that
they're you know much more politically
savvy than the average American the the
DNC debates gonna be the first time any
Americans have ever seen or heard of
Andrew yeah so rather than try and have
some zinger like I just need to have a
chance to express you know my beliefs
that we need to make this economy work
for work for people work for families
work for Americans and that we need to
think bigger about what that means the
21st century so you know like I'm really
excited about the opportunity in both
June and July and from it's from a
tactical standpoint does it even make
sense for 2020 candidates to be talking
about Russia and Moeller at this point
or is it best to just let that be what
it is and focus on a platform for 2020
well you know I've always thought the
job was to beat Donald Trump at the
ballot box and we need to solve the
problems that got him elected in the
first place and to me the central
problem I got him elected is economic
stress and distress around the country
where 70 percent of Americans are living
paycheck to paycheck 57 percent can't
afford unexpected $500 bill there's a
mindset of scarcity that is sweeping our
country and that helped get Donald Trump
elected and that's what we need to fix
so there are tons of people talking
about muller and russia but i don't
think it's my job to be one of them all
right Andrew yang is running as a
Democrat for president in 2020 Andrew
I appreciate you taking time out of your
increasingly busy schedule to talk to us
hey David you're one of the originals so
I will always come back for you because
like no like no matter how cool I get
and if I win like I'll 100% do an
interview from the White House with you
what that we that is recorded
fortunately we have that on video for
sure thanks Andrew really appreciate
your time
thanks David you too